what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with donnie kate smashernaut
with the finale and we finally get the
titan hulk the most powerful version of
the hulk that we've ever seen now for
those of you guys who want to get caught
up make sure you check the link in the
description or you can click on the card
here in the video which will take you to
the hulk playlist that will get you
caught up on all this stuff but the long
and short of it is that the incredible
hulk is basically here in an alternate
reality and is facing off against these
altered versions of the hulk basically
um these accidentally created versions
but the thing about this is that
remember bruce banner was the one
controlling the body of the hulk and
that the incredible hulk persona is in
the engine room basically serving as a
source of power because of its anger and
that somehow an alternate personality
which seems to be brian banner although
donnie kate's hasn't necessarily
confirmed it has now seized control so
it's like if the incredible hulk body
was being controlled by an evil
personality is basically what it is now
the way in which uh bruce banner
basically amped up the incredible hulk
or brought him down in terms of like how
much power he would need to face off
against a particular threat was
basically forcing the incredible hulk
personality to fight different levels of
villains that are out there so at the
baseline level is like the incredible
hulk just walking along right and maybe
fighting fighting some guy or you know
fighting the avengers or something like
that in the real world and so in the
engine room it would be these baseline
villains really like nobody of any real
significance what we're seeing here is
what happens when that's amped up all
the way to 10 when basically it's the
most amount of power that could be taken
out of the incredible hulk right like
literally pushing him to his to his
highest level now donnie kate's doesn't
necessarily confirm this but what he
says here or at least what this
indicates is if this is the most amount
of strength the incredible hulk can
possibly offer basically pushing him to
the limit then it's way beyond anything
we've ever seen and the highest amount
of power that we'd seen from the
incredible hulk up to this point was
heart of the monster when he was so
strong he was actually breaking the dark
dimension the the dimension of dormammu
which at the time was ruled by his
sister umar who literally showed up in
the maine marvel universe asking doctor
strange for help because the incredible
hulk just couldn't be stopped i mean it
was crazy how powerful he was still one
of the best stories ever again that's in
the playlist as well if you guys want to
get caught up on that but the thing
about this is that with this personality
running the show it's really just kind
of offering this amazing meta commentary
coming in the form of betty ross albeit
seemingly actually being somebody else
what we're told here is that it says
everyone always says the same thing that
the hulk is bruce's identity right his
alter ego the embodiment of a scared
little boy overwhelmed with impotent
rage because of the abuse he endured
when he was a little kid blah blah blah
blah yadda yadda right she just kind of
shuffles it off and that's true that's
one of the best things about this is
donnie kade's kind of offering this meta
commentary now for those of you guys who
don't know what this means as we're
going through this i'll kind of give you
guys a little bit of a little bit of a
background here although you do get an
amazing moment where you basically have
like when it's amped up to level 10
which according to bruce banner is
basically theoretical he doesn't even
really know what would happen if that
were the case that basically it's the
hulk versus the entire marvel universe
which in which includes the living
tribunal thanos and a version of
galactus who is the hulk now there's a
reason behind that and i'll explain that
here in a second because unless you're
familiar with galactus you wouldn't know
why galactus looks like the incredible
hulk and even this personality doesn't
know which is uh which is a really
really cool concept so the thing about
this is that when it comes to
the incredible hulk mythos most people
out here whenever they go and they buy
an incredible whole comic book and they
read an incredible whole comic book what
they want to see is the incredible hulk
just smashing that's what they want to
see
[Laughter]
they want to see the incredible hulk
fighting really powerful people and
beating them up and just tearing things
up because that's what the hulk is known
for now people who want a more like
character-centric run that was the old
bill mantlow and peter david stuff greg
pack focused on that to a degree but it
was more expanding the incredible hulk
mythos and then focusing on like the
character of the hulk insofar as it
related to like hirokala and scar the
sons he didn't know he had which were
really really cool and there were a few
other things that went in there but in
terms of like a character deconstruction
of the hulk what's being referenced here
in terms of the fact that like the
incredible whole personality is the
physical manifestation of just all the
rage that bruce banner experienced at
the hands of his father's abuse that's
all bill mantlow and peter david it was
initially started by bill mantlo back in
the day but he took off before he could
finish and then peter david continued it
on and that's why one a lot of people
say the two go hand in hand that when it
comes to that era of the incredible hulk
is bill manlow and peter david together
and two a lot of people say that peter
david's run of the incredible hulk is
one of the most important runs it's not
the most interesting run especially when
you compare it to something like greg
pack which had a lot more action and a
lot more character development but in
terms of everything greg pack did that
was built on the shoulders of peter
david so peter david's run it's probably
one of the most significant runs but for
no other reason than the fact that it
just sort of changed the hulk from like
the old stanley jack kirby days where
he's just like you know a monster
running around with the mind of a child
and like beating things up and like
fighting general thunderbolt ross and
his army and so on and so forth
especially if you look at the roy thomas
era as well and it changed him into like
there's actually more to the incredible
hulk than we initially thought now as
far as this whole scenario goes when it
comes to like why uh galactus looks like
the incredible hulk i mean technically
it is the incredible hulk versus
galactus the living tribunal and the
phoenix force it is here in the engine
room but the reason why is something
that was established in a story called
the trial of reed richards and we talked
about this before but basically that set
up the idea that galactus does not
actually have a physical form anymore he
did back when he was gallon before his
universe before the multiverse was
destroyed and then he re-emerged after
merging with that universe's version of
eternity essentially when he was reborn
into the new universe as galactus uh he
had a human form back when he was
initially just what you would call a
human or a sentient being but when he
was reborn as galactus he's pure energy
and so if you saw him as he really is it
would just be a swirling mass of energy
inside of a giant purple suit and
there's one point where odin like
headbutts galactus and shatters his
helmet which i'm pretty sure we did a
video on that and that in turn you
actually see galactus in what looks like
his human form but the reality here is
it's how an asgardian would see him
because in the trial of reed richards
what they set up and what they stated is
that galactus is a mirror for whatever
race or whatever being sees him so if
you are a scroll and you see galactus he
will look like a scroll if you are a
cree he'll look like a kree if you're a
human he'll look human and so if you're
an asgardian he'll probably look like an
asgardian which is why in this instance
the incredible hulk sees galactus and he
sees an incredible hulk so so the thing
about this and what's really cool is the
hulk literally amps up and starts
attacking everything right starts
attacking all of them now the funny
thing about this is during this whole
this whole situation the entire
monologue offered by this betty brandt
we can call her betty brandt right this
betty brand-esque person which is most
likely brian banner that literally it
says over the years there have been so
many hulks gray ones red ones blue ones
wolverine ones which is actually called
weapon h and he was not that interesting
uh she says it seems to me that well
everyone gets to have a hulk these days
bruce has a hulk rick jones had a hulk
general thunderbolt ross had a hulk
jennifer walters even had a hulk and she
said hell even god has a hulk which is
cool to see donny cates referencing the
al yuing run where we basically learned
that the the one below all is what
happens when god hulks out and so she's
like it's really unfair isn't it like
why can't the hulk have a hulk now this
and this gives us two things one is a
retcon that everyone's glide happened
and two is a new version of the hulk and
so what we end up getting like as this
fight goes on technically the betty ross
persona is in the mind of the incredible
hulk in the real world the incredible
hulk is fighting in this alternate
reality against like all these different
just grotesque and mutilated versions of
the hulk remember in this alternate
universe there was an effort to
basically utilize gamma energy as a
source of renewable energy things went
wrong and instead of becoming a
renewable energy source it ended up
mutating a whole host of the world's
population into these different versions
of the hulk and that's what the
incredible hulk's fighting now in the
real world so that's why i say it's
something to kind of keep in mind donnie
kate's does it a little finicky right he
does a little a little weird but
essentially anytime you see somebody
that looks like they're in a cockpit
they're in the mind of the incredible
hulk when you see the version of the
incredible hulk that looks like a robot
kind of that's basically him in the real
world so just something to keep in mind
here the thing about this is that as
this fight goes on because the hulk is
being so readily overpowered and quite
literally being slapped around what it
ends up doing is the incredible hulk
himself hulks out now this is something
marvel had done before and it was ass so
in the story of axis basically the
incredible hulk hulked out into
basically claw which was the incredible
hulk spelled backwards it was a terrible
idea uh ridiculously dumb and so what we
got instead of that was this like donnie
cage just being like this is what
happens when the hulk hulks out uh he
ends up becoming the titan hulk which is
nuts because he literally looks part
machine like it's just ridiculously op
which is absolutely amazing i love this
i mean dude the guy's just spewing
energy everywhere but this is why i say
this is what it looks like this is
seemingly the most powerful version of
the incredible hulk that we've ever seen
now there there are huge differences
between this version of the hulk and
like heart of the monster in looking at
these two you kind of have to come from
a feats perspective and in terms of like
what each one is capable of we saw what
the heart of the monster hulk was able
to do i mean again shattering and like
breaking apart the dimension of one of
the most powerful magic wielders in
existence which depending on who's
writing the story dwarfs the power of
doctor strange that is crazy like
literally them having to take off on
their dimension and ask doctor strange
for help to deal with that version of
the incredible hull so we're not really
seeing those same levels of feats now i
would be curious to see what happens if
the titan hulk ends up in the dark
dimension again and how that unfolds it
would be pretty wild and it would be
pretty cool but this is what happens
when the incredible hulk's just strength
rage anger all that kind of stuff and
really fear take hold and is pushed to
the absolute limit we just get this
massively grotesque huge thing right and
literally what what they're saying is
they're like i've never seen anything
like this before it's like 30 feet tall
like this thing is enormous right i mean
he's just huge like it's just it's it's
amazing
[Laughter]
i absolutely love this so again here in
the real world in this alternate reality
you have general thunderbolt ross and
you have this alternate reality version
of bruce banner and this alternate
version of bruce was in a lot of ways
kind of subservient to general
thunderbolt ross but only in so far as
this alternate reality version of bruce
was basically a coward wrecked by guilt
and fear and so on and so forth and so
the reality here is thunderbolt ross
basically ends up getting on getting on
the radio and calling in like a gamma
bomb detonation now the way this works
seemingly what would happen here is
somehow gamma radiation has been altered
by general thunderbolt ross to where
it's more akin to like a nuclear
explosion right enough that it would
just eradicate everything here and in
truth usually when it comes to like a
nuclear bomb or something like that it's
a combination of heat and force and
radiation right i mean if you're at
ground zero when a nuclear warhead goes
off or a nuclear bomb detonates which
technically it doesn't detonate on the
ground it detonates a little into a
little above ground ah just to maximize
the area of destruction i mean you would
be incinerated by the heat immediately
and assuming you weren't incinerated by
the heat if you're close enough to the
blast i mean you'd probably be knocked
into a building and just just killed
that way right your skull would be
crushed by the impact but assuming that
doesn't happen the radiation sickness
would probably kill you as well right i
mean there's a lot of ways to die as a
result of a nuclear bomb going off but
like that really seems to be what it is
here right it would just be like like
literally just heat and pressure it's
basically what general thunderbolt ross
is banking on whether or not it would
work we don't know i mean there are
literally been instances where like the
incredible hulk who's just kind of angry
has been able to withstand the power of
a nuclear bomb even maestro right like
literally maestro hulk absorbed the
radiation that came from nuclear bombs
so we've seen different variations of
the hulk over the years who could easily
withstand a nuclear explosion how a
gamma a weaponized gamma explosion would
impact the hulk i don't entirely know i
mean literally the hulk is living gamma
radiation my assumption would be that he
would just absorb it but the reality
here and the point that this alternate
version of bruce banner brings up is
that thunderbolt ross can't do that like
it's a terrible thing to do because if
he did thousands of people would die
because while we don't see them because
they're not the main focus here they're
there's basically a populated area right
it's not overly populated and they kind
of seem to be off out there and a little
bit of a distance but the the explosion
radius would be high enough it would be
wide enough that it would kill so many
innocent people and that in turn
thunderbolt ross just kind of like
overpowering or really just sort of
directing bruce banner is like no like i
don't care in the end like we'll both
end up killing thousands of people he
says because remember you're the reason
why these different versions of the hulk
exist in the first place and you're the
one that brought this alternate hulk
here so really this is all your fault
now the reality here is his thunderbolt
ross to a degree trying to assuage his
guilty conscience if he even has one and
just trying to bring bruce banner down
with him but where this version of bruce
is kind of a depiction of what would
happen if bruce banner just never grew
any balls he never became the incredible
hulk and was never like an enemy of
thunderbolt ross and so far as he was
able to overpower him likely humiliate
him a few times that the only thing he
really can do is muster up what courage
he has and he in turn attacks
thunderbolt ross and is like no i'm not
going to let you kill thousands of
people now while you know within the
context of this particular story it
doesn't seem significant or at least
this particular video over the course of
the videos that we've covered it's a
huge moment because this alternate
reality version of bruce was constantly
racked by guilt and constantly felt like
he was making terrible mistakes and even
then he didn't realize that where he was
basically sending all these different
versions of the hulk that they caught
across their world into the ether right
into some into some portal somewhere
with no clue where they went to that
what was really going on is that he was
sending the ones out there that general
thunderbolt ross didn't want that what
thunderbolt ross was doing was going
around and grabbing those different
versions of the hulk that he could use
that were that he thought were
weaponized so in reality he was at least
by his own imagination and kind of using
his own mind feeding into his own guilt
he was the reason why all these
different abominaze versions of the hulk
were continuing to live these terrible
existences under the servitude of
general thunderbolt ross because he
didn't know but had he not done what he
done in creating the gamma detonation
trying to create some kind of renewable
energy they never would have been left
to that fate in the first place so the
screwed up world in which bruce banner
lives here he largely takes as being his
fault him attacking thunderbolt ross
overpowering him pointing that gun at
him and saying no like you're not going
to kill anybody anymore this is
seemingly him overcoming that guilt and
accepting that not everything bad that's
going on now is his fault right that
like there are some things out there
that are just the results of the fact
that people are dicks right like gender
general thunderball ross is just a
terrible person who is doing terrible
things and despite what thunderbolt ross
said it was not the fault of bruce
spanish now the other part of this is
that in the mindscape of the incredible
hulk bruce banner kind of claws his way
back into to the incredible hulk's mind
more or less where he was just kind of
out there basically it was a it was an
in-comic representation of the fact that
like the bruce banner persona was forced
to take a back seat so ultimately of
course with him coming back in we do get
this version of betty ross's personality
which seemingly kind of alters and kind
of changes and takes on this different
form again we don't know exactly what
this is but i would go as far as to say
if the titan hulk is what happens when
the hulk hooks out that this is the
mental representation of what the titan
hulk looks like we don't know that for
sure we're not 100 certain but in the
end there's this kind of discussion
where literally the personality is like
you have no power here banner right like
you are weak you are pathetic you cannot
take control you cannot wrestle control
of the body away from me and the
response of a banner is i know but he
has the power to do it and in doing so
flips the switch like literally hits the
emergency switch and allows the
incredible hulk persona to come in now
here's the thing it's amazing the way
this is drawn right like literally the
door is just half open and like the
incredible hulk persona is just there
and it's like the head of galactus is
behind him and he looks pissed and he
comes smashing in here so what you're
seeing here right now is basically a
battle of personalities right it's the
incredible hulk personality versus the
bruce banner personality versus whatever
this new alternate personality is which
is seemingly the personality of the
titan hulk i would go as far as to say
that was the case but the way this is
drawn can get really really
hairy and a little bit confusing and so
in essence what happens here is that in
the mind of the incredible hulk right
where you basically have the bruce
banner personality the titan hulk
personality and the incredible hulk
personality the incredible hulk
personality is able to beat back the
titan hulk personality in the real world
the titan hulk itself is literally just
unbridled energy that it just can't
control and so because it has all this
energy and because it doesn't know how
to control all this energy like this is
seemingly just a mindless thing it
literally just roars we never really
hear it speak or anything like that that
in the end all this energy just kind of
explodes in a massive explosion right it
just goes off right it literally just
blows up and so what you have here at
least momentarily is essentially a
reunification of personalities the titan
hulk personality has been beat back to
wherever it came from we don't really
know where it came from but presumably
it just resides down there in the
mindscape somewhere and that as a result
of the destruction of the quote unquote
real world titan hulk uh now it's
basically just the incredible hulk back
in its normal form and so at this point
banner basically runs back into the
cockpit right the mind of the incredible
hulk and in doing so resizes control and
as that goes on of course this gamma
bomb is falling and it is gonna it's
gonna cost so much life and so what ends
up happening is there's a conversation
between alternate reality banner and the
incredible hulk band right banner one
banner two banner three but you end up
having like this
this conversation between these where
alternate reality banner is like look
this gamma bombs falling you have to do
something right like i have an idea and
so you know prime banner we can call him
that banner from the main marvel
universe it's like then what do you want
me to do and alternate banners like i'm
opening a portal and basically that bomb
is going to come through that portal and
it's going to land here right it's going
to end up here where i am but in the end
it's the rightful thing to do i've
caused nothing but just death and
destruction and just horrible things uh
i wouldn't go i mean he doesn't go as
far as to say like it's the fate that
awaits me but he says like i really hope
that you don't end up like me i really
hope that you don't end up in this place
where you're basically like this kind of
horrible terrible villain what you have
here in the form of the incredible hulk
is quite literally a gift use it right
like use it as a gift treat it with
respect but use it to do good things now
this is actually a really really cool
concept because what this does is it
gives us perspective that the only real
perspective we have when it comes to the
incredible hulk is what we've seen over
the course of marvel comics and
potentially some alternate realities and
unless you're looking at like warren
ellis's marvel the end you don't really
see a whole lot of like totally screwed
up twisted up versions of the incredible
hulk but that's all this alternate
reality banner knows are just twisted
screwed up versions of the hulk and so
as a result of this once that bomb goes
through and of course it ends up
detonating that the portal is reopened
and banner or at least the incredible
hulk anyway travels through it to
wherever his destination ends up taking
him next he has no clue where it is that
he's going to end up going all he knows
is that literally at the moment the
hammer of all father thor which was
recently reassembled by angela and the
angels of heaven is making its way
towards the hulk so in essence what
we're apparently going to see here which
makes perfect sense because literally
it's the 60th anniversary of the
incredible hulk and thor fighting for
the first time that what we're going to
end up getting is all father thor
against probably the titan hulk which i
am ridiculously excited to see but with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end in order to make
all this easier to understand we're just
gonna make it into a full story it
should make it a whole lot easier to
follow but i will catch you all later
peace